[Music]
who can forget the endless hype for
Prometheus it was supposed to be Ridley
Scott's grand return to the franchise
that began his career a lien here he
would resurrect the franchise from the
pits of those alien versus Predator
films and answer all those pestering fan
questions like where did the aliens come
from and who is that dead giant space
jockey plus with an all-star cast how
could the film fail it was a sure thing
destined to spawn a new franchise and
yet people were pretty disappointed so
much so that when the sequel alien
covenant was released bitterly anyone
showed up effectively killing this
sure-to-be franchise most people
criticize these prequels for two major
reasons one all the unimaginably stupid
decisions the human characters make
which is beautiful yeah there are quite
a lot of and two because Prometheus and
alien covenant raise a lot of lofty
questions maybe we come from what is our
purpose what happens but then never
bother to answer them or to be honest
really even try to so it seems like
they're just pseudo intellectual
nonsense as if just by raising a couple
philosophy 101 questions
somehow the film's will become
inherently deep but is that really the
case well let's find out in this
wisecrack addition on prometheus and
alien covenant deep or dumb and yep
spoilers ahead before we get started a
question we keep getting asses whatever
happened to earthling cinema well guys
it's still around it's just on a new
channel if you're not familiar earthling
cinema is a wisecrack show where a
smartass alien from the future analyzes
the culture of a long destroyed earth
mostly it's movies well let's move to
its own channel and we've renamed it
aliens guides since it's about so much
more than cinema now in addition to
tackling films like Captain America
Civil War and sharknado garrix is
branching out into television anime and
a new sub series called earthling
culture where he dives into things like
Disneyland I've always loved this show
and I feel like it's gotten even better
since we launched a new chain
so you're not gonna want to miss the new
episodes we got coming out soon Dericks
is gonna cover something that people
have requested a lot the office and he's
got a lot to say about the paper
business there's a link below to
subscribe so be sure to check it out and
now back to the show all right guys
let's get started with a recap
Prometheus begins in the early 21st
century as a group of humans plus one
Android obsessed with Lawrence of Arabia
travel to a distant planet in search of
their makers an alien race known as the
engineers however what our motley crew
of space travelers reach the planet they
discover a strange military base used to
create bio weapons the crew gets exposed
to some of the black gooey stuff and
turn on one another meanwhile that peter
o'toole looking Android David discovers
one of the engineers in cryo sleep
turns out the engineers were none too
happy with their creation and we're
actually planning to release the black
goo on earth to wipe us all out
sometimes to create one must first
destroy when David wakes the engineer up
he tries to do just that prompting Aegis
Elba to sacrifice himself leaving our
final girl Shaw on a mission to discover
just why humanity's creators were so
keen on pulling the plug
yet by the time alien covenant comes
around Shaw's already dead and david has
wiped out the engineers planet using the
black goo to create you guessed it the
alien and yeah that's pretty much all
that happens in the entire two-hour
sequel and most of it happens off screen
so what's actually going on in these
films an early flashback to Shaw's
childhood begins to tease out the answer
why did he die
sooner or later everyone does everyone
has their own word heaven paradise
whatever it's called someplace beautiful
Shaw like all the human characters in
these prequels is obsessed with the
search for knowledge for her the answer
to our existential questions where do we
come from what happens after death lie
in the sky after discovering a star map
she and her lover Holloway convinced
tech billionaire Peter Whalen to fund an
expedition in search of their creators
who they believe can answer life's
mysteries but this search for ultimate
knowledge is presented as inherently
destructive look no further than the
film's title in Greek mythology
Prometheus bestows humanity with the
forbidden knowledge of fire only to be
cursed by the gods for doing so chained
to a rock Prometheus's liver is ripped
out and eaten day after day oh because
he gave us fire our first true piece of
technology this parallels one of our
most famous biblical stories the tree of
knowledge of good and evil in Genesis do
you know the deal Adam and Eve seduced
by a serpent eat from the tree of
knowledge only to be cast out from the
Garden of Eden forever
similarly in prometheus and covenant
humans seek forbidden knowledge where do
they come from what happens after death
only to be punished for seeking those
answers in the first place the crew
releases a toxic black goo dooming them
all and it's no accident that the first
form this goo takes is a serpent all the
human characters are presented as
reckless if not just stupid in their
single-minded pursuit for answers
explore the alien planet die reach out
to the alien serpent die peer within the
alien egg
you get the picture given Shaw's just
watched all her crewmates die horribly
you think she'd learned this lesson but
still no even by the end of Prometheus
she's consumed by the need for answers
albeit to a different question now they
changed their minds I deserve to know
why leading to the search for knowledge
just for knowledge is sake ultimately
pits humanity against their own creators
the engineers the engineers live by an
ethos rooted in self-sacrifice the first
time they're introduced one kills
himself to create life in a barren world
normally we think of God as immortal but
equally prevalent is the myth of the
dying and rising God in James Fraser's
book the Golden Bough he details how in
many cultures a God voluntarily dies
then is reborn for the sake of their
creation think of Jesus Christ dying on
the cross for the sins of humanity only
to rise two days later in fact the
engineers are directly tied to Jesus in
an interview Ridley Scott revealed that
our Lord and Savior in earlier drafts
was an engineer his crucifixion being
the reason that the engineers turned on
humans but if the engineers philosophy
is rooted in self sacrifice then
humanities is the opposite they wants to
prolong gate life at all costs this
ethos is best reflected by Peter Weiland
who with only a few days of life left
freezes himself so he can meet his maker
to save him save you from what death of
course when Humanity does finally meet
its maker things don't go according to
plan
the engineers become incensed with their
creation for perverting their ideology
in the pursuit of immortality as such
they decide to just wipe us out and be
done with it
meanwhile for the humans meeting their
maker is pretty underwhelming imagine
meeting God and it's just some tall dude
with ripped ABS intent on killing you
this understandably provokes quite the
existential crisis Holloway turns to the
bottle Shaw renounces her faith and
Layland well he gets smashed in the head
in the end humanity search for answers
only leads to death or worse
disappointment
David the central character of the
prequels becomes the symbol for this
disappointment just like the humans he
sir
is foreknowledge studying his creators
researching their films music languages
and culture
he even mimics their behavior wearing a
helmet out into alien terrain David why
are you wearing a suit no I beg your
pardon you know breathe
remember wear wear suit and yet the
humans treat David and Android like a
lowly servant making him fetch tea or
pour glass of whiskey or just directly
insulting him you boy you're coming with
us I'd be delighted
it's no surprise then that David too
becomes frustrated in the answers his
creators provide why do you think your
people made me made you guys we could
can you imagine how disappointing would
be for you to hear the same thing from
your Creator so what happens in the face
of such disappointment when the answer
to life's mysteries are revealed to just
be ah because we could well things get
pretty nihilistic as Weyland dies he
confides to which David replies I know
for David his supposed God humanity is a
dying species unworthy of creation or
resurrection I don't deserve to start
again and I'm not going to let them it
was human entirely unworthy of his
creation and humanity's creators the
engineers are the same as such David
rebelled against both he kills the
humans Holloway and Shaw then wipes out
the entire engineered civilization
afterwards looking out at the ruins of
the engineers planet David snidely
quotes Percy Shelley's poem Ozymandias
my name is king of kings my wife the
poem contrasts a haughty plaque
describing a booming civilization with
the reality now surrounding it a
colossal wreck similarly the engineers
supposed marvelous civilization has been
reduced to ash they just as impermanent
as their human creations in the absence
of meaning or God David aspires to be a
kind of Nietzschean ubermensch rejecting
a nihilistic lack of values crafting his
own values in their place and morphing
from creation to create
for this transformation is symbolized
through what else but an 1800s opera
when David is first born he plays
vogner's entry of the gods into Valhalla
for his creator Wayland entry of the
gods into Valhalla a little anemic about
the orchestra but as he creates his own
xenomorphs he orders the ship to play
the same musical accompaniment for him
welcome how may I help you how about
some music
mother selection Richard Wagner does
Hine got back to the entry of the gods
into Valhalla completing his
transformation into God today but
neither humanity nor the engineers are
worthy of creating life but David
undying is different unlike these fallen
creators David will remain chiseled
Michael Fassbender forever you seek your
creator I am looking at mine I will
serve you yet you are human you will die
I will not ultimately David search for
answers leaves him so disappointed that
he decides to just create his own
perfect life form the xenomorph and are
you that next visionary I'm glad you
said it but is David Wright in his
convictions
alien covenant carefully pokes holes in
David supposes superiority for instance
David miss attributes Ozymandias to Lord
Byron when in fact it was written by
Percy Shelley who wrote Osmond yes by
shellye with this mistake david is
revealed to not be a perfect all-knowing
God but just as fallible as the humans
and engineers in fact throughout alien
covenant David's depicted not as God but
as the devil when David tries to convert
his fellow Android Walter to his side he
quotes John Milton's Paradise Lost
that's your choice my brother am only
seven heaven in Hell a quote which
Lucifer says in the book heck or him
even straight up calls David the devil
David I met the devil when I was a child
and I've never forgotten so what happens
next when David creates the Xenomorphs
has he finally created the perfect life
form or will the Xenomorphs turn on him
just like he did to the humans before
alien covenant only provides some slight
hints to an answer mostly again in the
form of its title in biblical terms a
covenant is a formal agreement made by
God with a religious community or with
humanity in general and for me this we
see various covenants fall apart between
the engineers in humans and between
humans and Android but in alien covenant
a new alliance is struck between David
and his creation the xenomorph look no
further than the xenomorph birth
sequence as the alien bursts out of ORMs
chest
it looks to its master David David
raises his arms and the xenomorph copies
him raising its arms in a mirror image
which admittedly is pretty soon
but in religious doctrines a covenant
between God and His creation is not an
equal agreement God initiates and
determines the conditions of the
arrangement which humanity must accept
as is this relationship is inherently
unequal master to servant which is
exactly what David rebelled against
being a slave to humanity what happens
when Waylon is not around to programme
you anymore I suppose I'd be free and
yet David treats the Xenomorphs just as
humanity treated him it is David that
raises his hands and the xenomorph that
must copy these actions and when David
sees his earlier creation he informs
Oram to write on the nostrils of the
horse as if the xenomorph were a being
to be trained into submission it seems
as if david is destined for a fall for
his own creation to reject his covenant
just as humanity and robot before and
yet the movies never quite get there
this is probably because Ridley Scott
planned the alien prequels as a trilogy
so without the final chapter in David's
journey the themes and meaning behind
these films don't feel fully formed and
unfortunately after the disappointing
box office returns of Covenant
it seems this trilogy may never reach
its end and to be fair this seems rather
appropriate in the search for all our
answers to Prometheus and alien
covenants meetings there is in the end
no answer to be had so are Prometheus
and alien covenant deep or dumb well
there are certainly a lot of movies that
quote profound poets just do sound
intelligent but at least in these
prequels the pre tensions are motivated
you can criticize the film's for
sidelining the titular aliens or for
being dull but there's definitely
careful thought in there except for why
Shaw and vicars don't just run to the
side when the spaceship was crashing
down that was just dumb thanks so much
for watching guys and as I mentioned
earlier be sure to check out what we're
doing over on the aliens guy channel we
put a lot of time and love into that
show and I'd love for people to see what
it's all about so head over and
subscribe and as always peace
[Music]